voilà monsieur bonsoir l'étape
s'annonçait décisive
elle l'a été réservant même l'un de ses
coups de théâtre qui participent à la
légende du tour dix kilomètres avant
l'arrivée jan ullrich très bien parti
est tombé dans un virage alors qu'il
disposait d'une avance de deux secondes
sur son principal concurrent
lance armstrong l'américain a désormais
sa cinquième victoire à portée de roues
il a terminé l'épreuve troisième
il dispose désormais d'une avance d'une
minute 16 au classement général
l'épreuve contre la montre a été gagné
par l'écossais david millar qui avait
connu bien des déboires lors du prologue
compte rendu nathanaël de rincquesen la
dig picard un tour de france ça tient
parfois pas grand chose un virage mal
négocié et voilà les rêves de victoire
de jan ullrich qui s'envole juste
derrière même sam trombe lancé à pleine
vitesse ne laisse pas passer l'occasion
de reprendre quelques précieuses
secondes à son rival hulu je repars sans
conviction il a perdu le tour
quand j'écoute chute je vais être
inquiet tranquille et c'est pas
important pour le tap un maillot jaune
averti en vaut deux armstrong gère son
avance et ne prend aucun risque
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
où le riche roule en éclaireur à plus de
54 km heure de moyenne
les deux hommes arrivent canon dessus
des trombes d'eau oulrich à sa tête des
mauvais jours
il est 4e de l'étape est plus que jamais
deuxième du tour
voilà juste météo au bout
lalush 2
c'est dommage qui n'a pas gagné l'étape
accrue
cet après midi sur la ligne d'arrivée
malgré la pluie et la fatigue
lance armstrong s'est laissé aller à
quelques signes extérieurs de bonheur
cette victoire
l'américain est tout de suite allé la
partager avec sa femme de m'asseoir
lance amstrong rejoindra ont-ils merckx
hinault indurain dans la légende du tour
de france